side of this conference the news is
carrying what you have to say and to see
this conference Hall so full I think is
really really uplifting it feels like a
very very successful conference and it's
so it's great to be here again with you
as Minette said my first speech to your
conference was on zoom and it's not just
quite the same is it when it's all done
on zoom and I have to say there was a
moment over the weekend where I thought
I might have to do it again because you
will have seen the briefings that the
protocol discussions have been going
forward and it's been briefed over the
weekend that the protocol was going to
be signed off on Tuesday which would
have meant that just about now the Prime
Minister would be making a statement in
the House of Commons and I would be
happy to be back there with him
responding to it so I'm very glad for
the time being that the protocol hasn't
quite been signed off so I can be here
with you and it is fantastic
um to be here I have to say when I'm
asked to come to an nfu event
I never actually imagined a venue quite
like this in my heads I've got sort of
rolling fields in Yorkshire
um or perhaps your farm Monet beautiful
farm and beautiful countryside
um but you know here we are in
Birmingham
um and
you can take it from me the the local
Bull Ring isn't quite what you might
think here in Birmingham
but as it happens look there are farms
near here of course there are this is
Britain even in the most built up part
of our country you're never far from a
farm
I was on one this morning in solihull
with Rupert an nfu member naturally
um yes I was wearing my boots and my
bomber jacket on the farm as I was when
I came to your farm it actually took me
back because it's a little known fact
that my first job when I was about 14
year old was on a farm because I lived
on the Surrey Kent border perhaps that
wasn't a particularly sophisticated job
I was allocated to pick up stones in the
field which I've got about 50p but it
was a farm and it was my first job but I
spoke to Rupert in solihull on his farm
this morning he grows cereal crops
and tends to a herd of beef cattle so
he's got a mixed farm and we chatted
this morning and amongst the things that
he said to me he told me was that it
sometimes feels like Farmers aren't
listened to
and I thought about that because I talk
a lot about respect
now that's not something you can tax or
regulate
but it's a value that shapes how we see
the world how we feel about our country
I think it's really important
I saw this with my dad he was a tool
maker he worked in a factory with his
life and he was felt that people looked
down on him didn't respect him and what
he did
my sister's a care worker as it happens
what she feels about the respect shown
to her efforts in the pandemic by the
government
well I've probably better not share with
you but um conference my point is this
I obviously go round our country
and I know there's a feeling that
politics doesn't respect people
I know there's a sense that decisions
which affect communities are taken miles
away
by people with little empathy for their
challenges
that somehow politics is done to people
not with them
and I know this sentiment is especially
strong when it comes to farming and the
countryside
so let me start by acknowledging Labor's
role in that
it's not deliberate
we do care deeply about the countryside
but if we Face facts I think all too
often when I reflect on the labor party
we've come across as the party of urban
Britain
only mentioning the countryside to say
what we can't do
not what we can do
so if I only get one message across
today
let it be this this is a different labor
party
I won't bore you with all the details
but over the last three years since I've
been leader I've had intense focus on
changing our party and we've changed
that party from top to bottom
a party that's fit to serve
that's compassionate and competent
that aspires to govern for every corner
of our country
and yes that seeks a new relationship
with the countryside and farming
communities on that basis
and that has to see a relationship based
on respect
on genuine partnership
a teledanker from the CBI spoke this
morning just before lunch
and Tony knows that my labor party wants
to transform the way Britain is run
that we will give communities the tools
to control their economic destiny
and that can only be good for the
countryside
but also that we see real partnership
with businesses with unions with
communities as an economic imperative
that's the scale of the task
the damage this government has done
means that we all need to pull together
change how we go about things try
something new to get the growth our
country needs
and farming is a massive part of that
nearly 60 percent of the food we consume
renewable energy for 10 million homes
custodians of 70 of our land and of
course 4 million jobs
and then there's Net Zero
a Monumental challenge for this industry
but one that you've run towards
Net Zero by 2040 across England and
Wales is tough
but it's right
a reaffirmation of farming's role as
custodians of our natural environment
and if I may say so the sort of
leadership we need to drive our country
forward
I mean I want to thank you for that
leadership and thank this room for that
leadership because it's very very
important and for your openness it
always not only listening to Labor's
case but rightly challenging us when we
get things wrong the best decisions in
my experience the ones that are held up
to the right light and survive scrutiny
and the worst decisions are the ones
that have never been challenged and let
me assure this room that openness will
be reciprocated by my government if we
win the election next year
and Conference what I have from Nat what
I heard on the farm this morning
is the same as I hear from businesses
across the country
the need for certainty the stability for
a long-term strategy
this is not the place to waste words on
the government
but make no mistake
they aren't going to get this
they aren't going to understand the
chaos that they've caused and what the
cost is
I don't think they can change themselves
and they won't change our country
they're part of the broken system that
creates that feeling
that lack of respect for communities
across Britain
short-term crisis management
instead of long-term Solutions
I call it sticking class to politics
and it's at the heart of so many
challenges that grip our country right
now
distracted by short-term obsessions that
fixate Westminster
held back by cynicism which uses low
trust in politics as an excuse to narrow
our ambitions
and blinkered to the potential of an
active government setting the direction
we Lurch from crisis to crisis
always reacting always behind the curve
sticking plaster never occur
unable to raise our sights and nurture a
collective sense of mission
and farming is a cut and dry example of
this
you're going through a huge transition
with the environmental Land Management
schemes
in the main a good transition
A system that rewards public good is
right we can't lose sight of food
production
we can't lose sight of farming as a
business
but sometimes
because of the sheer breadth of
farming's contribution its social
importance to the environment and nature
to the countryside its way of life and
our national identity
we lose sight of farming's ultimate goal
we need that contribution and we need
sustainable food production you can have
both and labor will work with you to get
both
the conference look
I know this shift is everything to
British farming the stakes are so high
livelihoods are on the line
rolling these schemes out well is the
difference between viable farming
businesses
and abandoned Farms we can't have
underspends in the allocated money
we can't have Farmers struggling whilst
they wait for the right SFI standards to
be announced
we can't have everyone burnt out
by the bureaucracy and constantly moving
goal posts
it's too important
especially now in this trading
environment
your input costs energy fertilizer feed
gone through the roof
but the market pressure the social
pressure which comes with Rising food
prices that Still Remains you don't need
me to tell you all about that
every day seems to bring a new
existential risk to British farming from
bovine TV to alien flu and dramatic
changes to our climate
all that
losing a farm is not like losing any
other business
it can't come back
that's why the lack of urgency from the
government the lack of attention to
detail the lack of long-term planning
it's not on
you deserve better than that
you deserve a government that listens
that heed early warnings that shows the
level of ambition needed to tackle the
challenges you face
this is the country that developed a
vaccine for the world in less than 18
months
and yet it's nearly 15 years since the
threat of bovine TV escalated sharply
across the countryside
are we are we really saying an active
government a government with a purpose
couldn't do better than that
no
it's sticking past the politics
a way of governing Britain that will end
with my labor government
the conference
here's the challenge
any responsible incoming government
must take seriously the need for
certainty
the short-term attention spans in
Westminster I see them every day
they're part of the problem
but the world did change
when Russian tanks rolled into Ukraine
last year
and the war hasn't stopped
as you may have seen I went to Ukraine
last week
flew to the border with Poland
from there you get a train 12 hours on a
train into Kiev and that took me through
vast ways of Ukrainian Countryside and
farming lands and I could see for myself
the impact that this awful conflict is
having on the farmers and on their land
there
I had the privilege of meeting President
zielinski
and being able to say to him face to
face
that the support for Ukraine in the
United Kingdom is genuinely United there
will not be a political divide
and that should there be a change of
government at the next election next
year the support will remain the same
but the part of the trip that really
look at me most was going to the
outskirts of Kiev
where I went to some of the
neighborhoods that were most impacted in
the early days of the conflict and I had
seen before some of the images you
probably have seen them of civilians
blindfolded with their hands tied behind
their backs
and shot in the head
I went to talk to the people who had
gathered those bodies up on the roads
that I walked down with them
their friends their brothers and sisters
their Community they were left
to retrieve all those bodies and put
them into a mass grave which they dug in
the in the church that I was standing in
with them on Thursday of last week and
it was important it was certainly
humbling and their sense whether it's
farming or the railways that every day
they will go back to work they will not
be defeated if the railways are going to
get bombed they're going to rebuild them
and get the trains running again that
courage and resilience
was absolutely incredible to see and it
really brought home to me yet again just
how awful that conflict is and so I'm
very pleased that the solidarity this
conference has shown
in the face of the consequences is
inspiring
the solordy solidarity I think that
shows the best of our nation
standing shoulder to shoulder with
farmers who now till on the front line
of freedom
but the world did change
just under a year ago
and the consequences have to be managed
so on environmental Land Management I
say it's the right direction
and there's no point overturning the
apple cart
but where there are problems we will
work with the nfu
we will work with everyone who wants to
see the rural environment well managed
we will fix them
that's partnership
equally the principles that drive the
rock review into tenant farming are
sound
nothing shows the value of certainty
more clearly than this
tenant Farmers need a fair deal
they need to know their Futures are
secure
and look
I want to see more solar Farms across
the countryside
we've got high hopes for solar energy in
our green Prosperity plan
there'll be opportunities for Farmers
opportunities for Rural growth cheaper
bills
and in the long term real energy
Independence
but we can't do it by taking advantage
of tenant farmers Farmers producing good
British food on carefully maintained
fertile land
they can't plan properly if the soil
beneath their feet isn't secure
it's a huge barrier to plan sustainable
food production
and we've got to give them a fair deal
we've got to use our land well
got to do it conference because we need
food
the world has changed
feeding a changing world that's the
strap line here today
and it's true
that's the challenge
what's happened to energy production
since the war broke out shows where this
is heading
all around the world businesses are
looking again at the resilience of their
supply chains reacting to the crisis we
faced and will face in the future
and countries do the same
this is not protectionist
it's the reality of delivering National
resilience in our era
the former director general of MI5
baroness Eliza Manningham Buller has
said that food supply in her words is
part of our national security
she's right
food security is National Security
that's become very clear in the last 12
months
that's why the labor party is committed
to buying making and selling more in
Britain
we've committed to reforming public
procurement using it sensibly and
carefully to build up our Sovereign
communities in key Industries
it's a crucial aspect of our industrial
strategy our partnership
our plan for National resilience
and seasonal sustainable british-grown
food is a key part of it
so the next Labor government will commit
to this
50 percent of all food purchased by the
public sector will be food that's
locally produced and sustainable
by the way that's 1.2 billion pounds of
public money spent on quality food that
is genuinely better for People's Health
a clear-cut target for every year that
we're in government
oh look 50
is just the minimum we'll do everything
to go beyond it
we will buy more cereals more oil seed
rape more strawberries more beef more
British apples
and we will open up new opportunity to
export them as well
conference through
three further areas where labor will
combine certainty with change
and trade is the first
look
it's been obvious for a long time that
the conservative party has given up on
farmers
that trade deal with Australia
a win-win deal they called it but look
it's certainly a deal like no other
more than a 300 million pound hit to
British food and farming
and there's at least one Tory MP she's
still boasting about it
less Labor's approach to trade will be
very different I can promise you that
we want to remove barriers to exporters
not put them up protect High British
standards not water them down
understand that in trade distance
matters
everything in trade is up for
negotiation you can't make cast iron
guarantees
but we are going to talk to our friends
in the European Union
and we are going to seek a better
trading relationship for British farming
we're going to talk to them
about a new Veterinary agreement for
Agri products
and not just in Northern Ireland not
just to fix the protocol but for the
whole of the United Kingdom
the conference
just being serious about growth
means we have to have a plan for trade
but also
a plan to deal with the basic lack of
people
this is the second area where
partnership with labor will seek change
a tight labor market is crippling whole
sectors of our economy at the moment
and I know that farming has been hit
hard
I mean what's happening to Pig farming
is absolutely shocking
unlabor would not ignore that
we won't allow a situation where
temporary shortages gum up an entire
supply chain
that's anti-growth
it's anti-business
and it's anti-farming
equally of course
I know the seasonal nature of farm work
makes it unique
and that the seasonal worker route is a
distinctive solution to a distinctive
challenge
and we'll be pragmatic on that as well
but I also have to say
the reality is the era of abundant cheap
labor is over
that's not about brexit
it's a practical challenge we're going
to have to work through and solve
together
trust me all around the world
businesses are waking up to the fact we
live in a totally new era for labor
the world has changed
but it can be good for our economy and
good for farming if it's managed well
so any movement in our points-based
migration system
must come alongside a plan a shared
undertaking and understanding to move
forward to a different model
because over time our goal must be to
help the British economy off its
immigration dependency
to improve paying conditions where we
can work together to get the
technological innovation we need
deployed in our fields
and carefully move towards a new more
resilient model for British farming
a model where you're not nervously
waiting each year to see if you have the
staff
and where whoever's in power
you're less dependent on the home office
to stop food rotting in your fields
a conference
let me tell you one thing I won't accept
that rural communities should be
blighted by crime that routinely goes
unpunished
and this is the third area where we'll
offer change where labor always offers
change
Public Services
nobody should be waiting over an hour
and a half for an ambulance
nobody should get burgled time and again
with no prosecutions
nobody should be comfortable that mental
health support is scarcely available
and with all these problems
I know there are subtle differences that
make them even more worrying in rural
communities
you know
if the NHS is telling heart attack
patients to get a taxi
as they are in parts of our country
that's a lot scarier if you live in the
countryside
if your village has an anti-social
Behavior problem
or a fly-tipping problem or an off-road
biking problem
and the only police officers around are
in a station or custody Suite miles away
filing an arrest off the street for
hours
that's a unique problem
and if you're facing poor mental health
because of Stress and Anxiety which we
know is hidden challenge for many many
farmers
and there's a two-year waiting list for
treatment
that will harm rural communities
conference the truth is
some of this comes back to people as
well
so we have a plan fully costed
in the NHS
we'll get more doctors more nurses more
Health visitors delivering care in your
community
and in crime we'll get 13 000 more
police into our towns and villages
will police on Countryside streets
and we'll also have thousands more
well-trained mental health staff
which means we can guarantee treatment
for everyone who needs it within a month
but on public services it isn't just
enough to have more people
we also need to reform how we work
we need our health care to be delivered
where people are not just in hospitals
we need our police to be visible trusted
earning the respect of those they serve
we need our Mental Health Services to
understand the individual challenges we
each face
challenges that are different in the
countryside
all of this requires reform
all of this requires a different
approach
one that is designed from the start with
respect for the challenges of the
countryside
that's why dialogue and partnership are
so important
on every area on public services and our
economy
we need to show we're listening to the
distinctive concerns of rural
communities
work every day to build that
relationship of respect
I am so grateful to the respect the nfu
has shown me inviting me here every year
it gives me the chance to show how
important service to all our country is
for my labor party
because the challenges the countryside
faces that farming faces we need to take
them on together
that's why we're ready to listen
ready to partner ready to serve
a fair agreed a more Dynamic future for
British farming
certainty and change
stability and success environmental
stewardship and sustainable food
production you can have both
it's what labor will offer
what real National resilience looks like
and I look forward to working with you
to secure it thank you so much
conference
thank you
secure thank you I'm now really up
against it uh with the questions so we
will need to um be as as quick as we
possibly can and if I could have Mark
Gorton uh and Helen trinkel to the
microphones please and I'll kick it off
um you talked Zakir about the challenges
of of trade deals
um and the impact the negative impact
that they potentially will have and we
heard indeed Jim McMahon uh this morning
on the radio talking about the
challenges
um of the Australian trade deal and
being extremely critical I guess what
lessons do you take from this and what
would a labor government change uh well
look thank you Minette for starting with
that I mean of course we want to trade
across the world we want to be able to
export and therefore we want to reduce
barriers
but we have to be really clear I think
about standards and high standards I
think one of the biggest concerns about
trade deals now we've left the EU is
that there's a tendency an inclination
to drive standards down in order to get
deals and that is the wrong approach we
have to be clear that there have to be
high standards wired in to our trade
agreements that's why I'm concerned
about the Australian trade deal because
I do think it'll do real harm uh to
farming here to rural communities so yes
we want trade deals yes we want to
reduce barriers to those that need to
want to export we need to keep our
standards High we were the champions of
high standards we have very high
standards in this country and we need to
also recognize as I said in my speech
that when it comes to trade particularly
you know trade that involves
you know farming Etc distance matters we
trade more with our nearer neighbors
than we do with distant neighbors and
therefore we need high standards and a
decent deal and that's why we do not
accept that the deal we've got the
brexit deal we've got at the moment is
good enough and we will improve upon
that and make improvements for farming
thank you
um mark Wilson
thank you uh Minette good afternoon
Shakir and I'd like to talk to you about
or ask you about Labor
specifically your sort of labor but
labor as in Boots on the ground
I've from the poultry sector that can
probably speak on behalf of the
livestock sector in that we need workers
24 7 365 days a year to do hard manual
difficult jobs that unfortunately over
the last three or four years since
brexit we've found that it is very very
difficult if not impossible to recruit
those workers from the National Labor
Force so what can you tell us secure
that you would do in government to help
resolve that problem uh Mark let me
first start by acknowledging the problem
I think whichever particular sector of
farming you're in that tends to be a
problem whether it's Pig farming whether
it's poultry whether it's you know
picking apples and fruit
um
and you know things are now worse than
they were this has never been easy I've
been talking to Farmers for many years
now this is always an issue the seasonal
workers issue it's got a lot more acute
um in the last few years and I don't
think that we should take steps
um that
um inhibit you getting the staff you
need the people you need the laborers
you need right now so we don't want to
gum this up even more than it is already
and therefore we'll be pragmatic about
it but as I said in my speech I do and
this is a conversation we need to have
together I think the days of cheap labor
in the way that we have had for many
years are probably over for a whole
bunch of reasons and therefore we need
to work together to find a different way
forward I think I'm a great believer in
technology I know technology takes time
and therefore we've got to do this on a
gradual basis so
um you know a practical pragmatic
approach now which ensures that
um Farming Farming communities get the
labor they need now
and that's that's the sort of warm bath
bit of it but the hard bit is we are
going to have to change as we go forward
and we need to work together to ensure
that we bring about that change
um because I just don't see the model of
um of Labor operating in the future in
the way that it has in the past thank
you Mark
to be really really clear though on that
point you know we are a highly regulated
sector and you know this is this is not
a low pay sector at all indeed the
seasonal worker scheme that was outlined
this morning is absolutely in line with
the national living wage the scheme that
was outlined last year the season
agricultural worker scheme was set above
our own National living wage so you know
many guys whereas these guys have had to
absorb huge cost
um at their own business expense to pay
a higher rate of pay so I think it's
it's really important you don't see this
sector as as low pay I think there are
challenges in getting a fair return for
what we're producing which is which is a
massive issue right now
um if I could have Andrew broadly uh to
the microphone and take Helen's question
now Helen
at secchia I believe under a labor
government public rights over private
land will be extended through right to
Rome are you aware of how disastrous
this will be for Urban Fringe Farmers
like myself for whom the general public
already caused a lot of issues
an extension of right to room could
essentially write off productive
livestock fields in our area especially
during sensitive times in the farming
calendar
this is both from an animal welfare and
farm safety perspective
foreign
thank you for raising that and I can see
how important it is to everyone in the
room look I do believe in the right to
roam but we need to Define what that
means it's got to come with rights and
responsibilities because we can't have a
right to Rome that tramples
um on the businesses of farmers and
therefore whatever we do on this Helen
and everybody in this room we will do it
in conjunction with you we'll have that
discussion how does this look what are
the rights and responsibilities people
do want freedom to be able to walk
across our fantastic Countryside but
it's got to come with responsibilities
because we can't have any right to Rome
that interferes
um with the business and viability
interests of farmers so I tell you today
I'm very happy to work with you on this
rather than to press ahead of it with it
on our own to talk through what that
looks like what the framework might be
so that you have the sense of comfort
and security that this is something
which doesn't have the impact which you
obviously fear from the reaction Helen
to your question so yes I believe in the
right to Rome but yes I believe the
partnership working I was describing
means I want starting today to talk to
you about what that might look like so
that you can say this is how it should
be shaped so that it doesn't in fact
infringe on the very legitimate concerns
that you're raising with me
huge concerns I have a livestock
worrying indeed livestock Slaughter from
dogs that are on on the loose we have an
incredible network of footpaths and
Bridal ways that are actually unlike any
other country in the world to allow
people to access but your point on doing
it responsibly is is going to be
absolutely key you know and for the
environment ground nesting birds and
everything else so
um you have and we're thrilled to hear
it committed to work with us and we look
forward to doing that
um Andrew broadly
thank you madam president secure
can you please confirm that labor will
continue to follow the science when it
comes to disease eradication
especially that of btb
where the control of wildlife alongside
every other tool has been proven to work
Andrew I'm a great believer in following
the science
um and again we'll work with you on this
that this has been around as I said my
speech for a very long time now
um and still we don't we haven't made
the progress that we need to if we're a
nation that's capable of producing a
vaccine for the pandemic in an
extraordinarily fast period of time and
rolling it out we have to move faster
and better and quicker on issues like
this so yes we'll follow the signs yes
we'll work with you but also we'll put
our shoulder to the wheel I do not
believe it should take this long for us
to make progress on this issue which I
know is a real concern
um you know to so many farmers the the
the impact that this has on on livestock
um you know where I mean you're all
rightly very very concerned about
um even the prospect of this happening
so yes follow the science yes work with
you yes I do believe we should further
and faster and I think we can we've
proved as a nation what we can do when
we really put our shoulder to the wheel
when we were faced with the pandemic we
should take that model and use it all
the time in everything that we do in
government
you're absolutely right to make the
points to care about livestock but the
the human impact of this disease
um it is impossible to put it into words
when you get a breakdown on your farm
and you have told that your herd has
gone down with bovine TB I I don't think
anything gets any worse the human impact
is inculcable because your hands are
tied behind your back to a certain
extent and it's just worth pointing out
that we've got the lowest levels of
disease outbreaks that we've had in in
years and years so sticking with the
science sticking with the evidence
eradicating this disease and ridding our
country a number of farmers have
described to me the sort of the the fear
of sort of waking up and being fronted
with this reality and so on a human
level it's it's one of those things that
people genuinely have sort of nightmares
about you just do not cannot
um you talk about mental health and
rightly so there is nothing that will
cause mental health breakdown more more
yes can I know we're out of time oh by
quite a bit um can I just get one more
question in of course please Tim Dobson
can you run to the microphone please
there's a lot of people getting up okay
yeah
Tim Tim
conference
um looking at bringing in migrant labor
into the
Marketplace
it seems far more attractive for labor
to stay in Europe where they're actually
wanted and needed them to come here
what will you do to make the
UK a more attractive place so that our
Pig Farmers our poultry Farmers our
fruit farmers can attract workers to
come to the to work for us
uh well Tim look thank you for raising
that because obviously the situation
the situation has changed in the last
few years I'm not going to pretend I
mean I was talking to Farmers back in
2015 2016.
um before we had the referendum and
there were real problems then with
seasonal workers and how the seasonal
worker schemes work so this has been an
ongoing problem it's got a lot more
acute
um we have to make this an attractive
place for people to work to come to but
we also need to look at longer term
Solutions as well using technology
Etc we need to look at our own Workforce
as well we've got many many people
um out of work out of the labor market
here who only two or three years ago
were in the labor market so I think Tim
there's a lot we can do together on this
but as to the acuteness of the problem
that you're facing I absolutely get it
if you can't get the labor rate then
it's you know whether it's whether it's
Pig farming poultry fruit farming it has
such an impact so we have to find a way
through this together we also have to
have a sense of purpose for our country
one of the
um
tragedies I think of the last few years
I don't want to get too party political
because this is not the place but um the
drifting of the UK off the international
stage the sense of drift as a nation
without purpose I think is having a
profound effect
um on our economy and our well-being our
economy hasn't grown significantly for
the best part of 13 years this is a
massive problem
across the country including in farming
if you don't have a thriving economy
then there's a sense of drift and we
have to address that I think as a
country and that will be one of the
major missions if you like of an
incoming labor government
the joys of this you never know quite
what questions are going to be asked so
actually the question I had uh down from
uh Tim Dobson is why should Farmers vote
labor at the next election uh he goes on
to quickly say secure the labor party
traditionally doesn't have a high level
of support in rural constituencies yet
Farmers tend to do better under a labor
government how do you plan to persuade
Farmers to vote for you at the next
election well the first thing uh Tim
thank you for that
he's got two bites at the same time Tim
thank you for that question you got your
first question in your second one which
you censored look
um I want to be absolutely clear today
and it's something I think I said at the
first conference I addressed or be that
one was on Zoom that I want the labor
party to say as much about rural issues
as it does about Urban issues
um there's a reason that um two years
ago when I first addressed this
conference I was the first labor leader
for I think over a decade to address
this conference because I wanted to come
and have this dialogue I know how
important it is
um that all of the rural issues and
concerns that you have are addressed I I
grew up in rural on the border of of
Surrey and Kent I lived in a rural
community I know the impact that these
issues have on farming on our
communities on our Countryside so it's
deep in my DNA but if I can Tim
um say one thing that is about rural
communities but in rural farming but
it's broader than that it is what we
will bring into government
um as a labor government is a different
approach to governing I am fed up to the
back teeth with sticking plaster
politics with the idea that you just
don't take long-term decisions you wait
for a crisis to unfold and then you do
the minimum necessary to get through the
crisis and go on and there are so many
examples of this we've had a winter NHS
crisis every year for the last 13 years
the other thing is it gets worse every
year and every year we have a sticking
plaster that just about gets us through
until the spring we breathe again in the
summer and then we go back into a crisis
the next winter because we don't do the
long-term planning we don't do
partnership work same thing with energy
I mean you were saying this morning
about the devastating effect that higher
energy bills are going to have or could
potentially have on energy intensive
farming
and of course that is now a short-term
crisis that has to be addressed I do
think there should be more money for
energy intensive businesses and farming
is including that but that's plaster
that's to get us through this crisis
what we really should have done is to
run towards Renewables 10 years ago what
we really should have done is to
insulate our homes 10 years ago we
should have gone down this road but we
didn't do strategic thinking and so Tim
if there's one thing I want to get
across it is that I feel a sense of
drift in our country at the moment I'd
really invite everybody in this audience
to ask themselves do I feel better off
than I did 13 years ago is our economy
working better than it did 13 years ago
our public service is better than they
were 13 years ago and if they asked all
those questions is no then there's a
very very powerful case for change and
what we would bring in change is not
just what we would do but how we would
do it and we will govern
in partnership with yourselves and
businesses and as I Tony dank and I've
talked about this at Great length there
it's
two or three models for government one
is the government gets elected in and
says well we got elected we've got the
band date we'll suck it all up to the
center take decisions in Westminster and
Whitehall and do a sort of command and
control that is wrong it won't work and
we wouldn't do it the other is to say
well we've got elected in we've got a
mandate but the market always knows best
let's just leave it to the market I
don't think that works anymore it
certainly doesn't work in farming or and
this is our approach we will form and
Forge a genuine partnership with
businesses with farming communities with
others to actually do this together
where the government says this is what
we're trying to achieve but we need to
achieve it with you each understanding
what the other has to do the government
doesn't need to do what you do
but the government or a labor government
coming in needs to understand what you
need a labor government why I like The
Challenge from the net because I need to
know what are the levers that you want
us to pull in government that will allow
you to get on and prosper in what you
want to do I don't want to do your job I
want to make it easier for you to do
your job so you can Thrive and prosper
and that's the nature of government Tim
it's more than just what we'll do it's
how we'll do it
conference I am well over time it's fair
to say your team are looking as angry as
my team
so there we go
um thank you for having me conference
please show your appreciations take care
of Summer
thank you very much thank you for having
me